so this this relationship you have with
Jim this is like one of the great
Hollywood working collaborative
relationships what is it like to have
someone that you know that you can just
trust with whatever their vision is yes
I mean that is such a wonderful part of
it
um I think Jim's one of the smartest
people I know he knows about science as
almost as a scientist
um and that he is
made his life be about telling stories
telling stories about things that are
meaning meaningful to him and about the
worlds he loves like underwater
um
to be able to have Jim as a colleague
and
to have him you know entrust me with a
role like Kerry who's such a Soulful
unusual girl who's 14. I was so honored
you know and kind of terrified honored
uh amused because he said you know
you're so mature that this will be easy
for you
so we have that kind of playful
relationship but you know if I was in
trouble I would definitely call Jim yeah
well Kyrie is really cool like this is
the kind of role that I don't think you
typically get to do on film like in
theater perhaps voice over perhaps but
to get to embody this character
haven't gone back to like study
teenagers and hang out with teenagers
would you want to go back and actually
be 14 again no
no I'm afraid not I mean I think as you
get older you do get
more accepting of of who you are what
you are and um and I love being with the
my fellow actors who were 7 and 12 and
you know whatever they were back then
I'm very grateful to them for allowing
me looking the way I do at 70 well I
guess I was 60 something but um you know
they had to be so courageous in in
allowing me to be 14. I think they
should all get an award for that you
know just like letting you be in the
fold yeah letting me be a kid with them
that's cool and they're not going you
know right maybe she didn't see it yeah
they have a really sneaky way as soon as
I leave the room they do that
now I'm also very obsessed with this
idea that you all were filming
underwater spending so much time down
there and the story is of you know
holding your breath for six minutes
while performing six and a half pardon
me I don't want to discredit those 30
seconds we're really tough well it's
true even like I mean I haven't done any
breath training so doing 30 seconds
underwater is a bit of a you know
sometimes a bit of a stretch yeah but
you can do it with our teacher he
teaches the Navy Seals you could
absolutely do it you can hold your
breath for one minute in a pool if you
slow your heart down yeah it would not
be a problem for you and then you build
on that and you're also you learn how to
breathe up and you also the breath holds
are all static so it's something you do
to prepare for a scene uh and you're
also in in our case we were Sometimes
using augmented oxygen certainly for
filming so we we have 30 oxygen in the
world for lucky and we had 50 to 80
percent okay well now you know yeah
thank you so much for the time such a
pleasure my pleasure and congratulations
on it we've been waiting a long time
congratulations thank you